this minecraft world is one block wide
and we have 100 players on it and these
100 players are gonna pvp to the death
and whoever is the last man standing
wins that ten thousand dollar jc penny's
gift card and no this video is not
sponsored one block wide map 100 players
pretty simple server let them break
blocks all right they can break flocks
oh wait what what if what if we did this
oh no
jimmy watch this if somebody digs
straight down
oh no they're getting stuck they should
have made tools oh this guy's going
straight down already if you go really
far away they just look like little ants
dude this really is a lot like an ant
farm yeah also i'd like to point out on
my screen right now there's about 15
crafting tables
chris chris chris chris do you believe
me hurry hurry hurry hurry uh somebody's
about to find this diamond in the dirt
oh oh
look he's got the jertsu skin oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh
oh no
wait this guy what is this guy doing oh
he found a sign if you're reading this
you are very cool oh he read it boys
boys set up more booby traps this is a
little too easy all right oh my gosh
carl you're right there's so many
crafting tables that's what i'm saying
oh this is digging straight down oh
he dug straight down into lava that's
why you don't do that man i think
they've had enough time to make some
weapons wouldn't you agree yeah so you
would say we should turn on pvp i i
think so server turn on pvp please this
is gonna be so chaotic all right pvp's
on oh they're fighting this one guy has
a sword and he's causing havoc kill him
oh oh my gosh this guy just slaughtered
people people are dying left and right
all right server turn off pvp turn off
pvp all right too many people are dying
let's give them another five minute
grace period jimmy can i put creepers
everywhere uh sure i'm already doing it
sorry you know what i just realized huh
they don't even know they're competing
for the coveted ten thousand dollar
jcpenney gift card
carl when you just stare at him it gives
it away oh this guy got a diamond yo
dude this guy's got a shield he's ready
for war oh i see there's a diamond here
but nobody has an iron pickaxe yet so
nobody's mining it hey everybody
what do you think you guys are competing
for
you guys are competing for a ten
thousand dollar jc penny gift card don't
get too excited what can it be
it can be best buy if best buy takes
jcpenney gift cards oh
have fun competing for the gift card bye
will he hear the creeper do our fans
still not play with headphones
they don't this is crazy oh someone's
minding diamonds carl did you put all
these diamonds down here no i actually
deleted diamonds there's so many
diamonds i kept deleting them oh he has
a diamond chest this guy is getting
diamonds for days so he basically just
went to the bottom and got a bunch wow i
think we should turn on pvp for three
minutes server if you wouldn't mind
oh they're going at it
no way dude no this guy's just a diamond
chest plate guy in the lava oh my gosh
oh ambush ambush
oh no oh mcdonald's man people are
getting slaughtered left and right some
people literally ran all the way to the
right side oh my gosh look at this this
one guy with the steve skin is all the
way on the right border all alone
[Music]
i love how like 50 people are competing
for the middle and then there's just
these guys just chilling look he's got
all the way up to the border
he just broke a diamond with a stone
pickaxe what are you doing this dude
right here just stripped mine and he
strip mined over all these diamonds he
literally could have had full diamond
armor if you just strip mined a few
blocks lower i'm gonna give them a sign
just give me a sign look
be low wink oh they're fighting right
there or they're fighting they're
fighting their fights
zeriak why aren't you mining all these
diamonds i don't have an iron pickaxe do
you want me to give you one yes if you
can make carl laugh in the next minute i
will give you an iron pickaxe okay okay
hit me with it hit me with it i am bad
at making people laugh
oh did you just laugh at that why are
you laughing is that so sad all right
here you go you earned it i don't know
how but you earned it
oh
my god he fell in one of our diamond
lava traps he would have actually done
better if we didn't give him the iron
pickaxe i'm actually so sorry i think
that was me that set that one on oh oh
oh there it is oh come on this is a
fortnight bro why you building so much
he's stuck but at least he has a diamond
shovel am i right oh this is they're
like fortnite they're cranking 90s right
now take a step back and look how
destroyed the map is now yeah dude it
doesn't even look like a
guys we started with 100 players and now
we're down to 26. they killed each other
so fast we couldn't even keep up with it
okay these people are straight up strip
mining to each other right now carl tp
to me chandler tp to me get rid of
everything in your inventory and switch
to survival oh
o'reilly okay you're both in survival
mode oh all right of course
all right i'm back alright i'm starting
now no channel you already died what
yeah you're out but carl you still gotta
try let's go
that's for killing chandler buddy you
don't just kill chandler and get away
with it all right so carl see if you can
win i'm gonna try actually i think i can
everyone is so spread out they're hardly
seeing each other servers shrink the
borders thank you very much so now it's
gonna push them all together and now
we're going to have some big fights it's
going to push them towards the middle
and push and push and push until one
person wins a ten thousand dollar jc
penny gift card comment down below what
gift card we should give away in our
next competition yeah why don't you buy
me a new life if i give you a second
life will that make you happy yes i will
actually have a chance to win all right
you have a second life all right now
it's fair i gave him a second life
because i know he's not gonna win yeah
it's fine what oh but i forgot the mic
y'all are playing against me already no
i just said i gave you a second life
because i know you won't win he's coming
oh
please no team who's coming is somebody
near you oh my god i hate you
wait did he kill you did you already die
hold on that doesn't count i don't have
the wood okay they spawned with wood
it's not fair 22 players remain
i just got one shot what chandler it's
okay it's just not meant to be what
about this we just let chandler play
with them he just let chandler have
unlimited lives yeah like taylor you
just take as many lives as you want this
is the answer he'll get bored before he
wins
[Music]
the border is coming in hot
no
where do i go chandler it's coming fast
go where these innocent players don't
even realize it but the zone's about to
come in on them oh my goodness all right
stop the zone stop the zone stop the
zone give them some time did you dodge
coral yeah i need a pick how do i have a
pickaxe oh my gosh they're towering
they're towering i'm gonna get this jc
penny car baby oh this dude's on a lot
fire oh
players remain these two are low on
health chandler go in for the sneak
attack
oh i'm not here hello
dude he turned around so fast put the
block underneath you bro so that way you
don't fall back oh he's coming he's
coming he's coming he's coming he's
coming look at this sweat you can see it
dripping seven players remain holy cow
dude this is close
he's up top above the leaves
oh oh oh no oh no don't do it mister how
did chandler get all diamond gear how
would you have a diamond axe i made some
mystery chests around the map
wait i'm so bad he's gonna kill me
nope oh
he built so quickly all right trailer
you gotta switch out for iron oh that
guy has no armor on i can't tell don't
kill him don't kill him i literally i
don't think he could and you had the
diamond armor in your inventory now that
we're done with the chandler arc there
is now six players remaining i want all
of you to pick a person and root for him
i call jacob i'm rooting for him i call
goofy i'm rooting for mir i got jeremo
sync don't dig into the llama oh my
goodness goofy i'm rooting for you
please i put down a sign saying i'm
rooting for you and then he put down a
sign saying whoa oh my guy's going in on
this guy oh my god he's fighting you're
fighting my guy yeah our guys are
fighting jacob jacob what are you doing
my guy's going after your guy don't die
stop check him check him check
him
build yeah
you suck that's my guy come on goofy
yeah get that lou goofy my guy's on the
pacifist row oh he's going for it oh
goofy look up goofy goofy goofy goober
oh goofy's not going down
my guy is eating and with those fallen
comrades three remain chris pick your
favorite carl pick your favorite
chandler pick your favorite i still have
my favorite here's what i want i want
you guys to get into isolated calls with
your contestant you can give them as
much information as you want but you
can't give them any items wait hold up
wait hurry and put me in the call with
him they're gonna die before you guys
getting a call with them meyer meyer
meyer meyer are you still alive mike
you're muted i see you right there hurry
hurry hurry hurry hurry hey bro
i have chosen you as the person i'm
gonna coach to winning hello what's up i
have picked you to win after you killed
me hey we're about to turn pvp back on
no no no no
pvp oh wait he fell
chris's dude just literally fell what
happened man sorry grace you were this
close to a ten thousand dollar jc petty
gift card hey my god died i'm here now
okay you're rooting for him also yep
he's gonna have a shield you can knock
his shield with an axe oh carl you're so
sweaty carl's being a good coach chris
let's go check in on chandler all right
hey how's everything going in here
pretty good he's pretty stacked he's got
it in the bag he's right he's literally
directly above you right yeah he's right
below you all right i moved you all in
the same chat now everyone is here 2v2
10 000 jc jcpenney gift card on the line
who will take home the dub oh he's
coming he's coming he's coming hey
really quick build behind you so you
don't get knocked back yeah that's
perfect you're a genius regina genius
keep doing it keep doing it keep doing
it yes yes meyer you're a genius go go
go don't get knocked back okay perfect
oh he doesn't have a shield you got this
you're good you're good use your shield
use your shield use your shield how did
he just float like that doesn't matter
he's dead
sink sink sink sink mr sink you just won
a ten thousand dollar jc penny gift card
there's a bit of a problem because we
don't really get jcpenney in canada so
in the comment section let him know how
much you'd buy a ten thousand dollar
gift card for awful i could just give
him 10 grand but that would be too easy
thank you for watching subscribe